hey guys I'm right right on Anthony I'm
glory Alba this right here is my brother
he goes by Anthony and this is his
daughter she goes by Chloe this is who
they are bringing them on the channel
today cuz they also have their own
YouTube channel and guess what they do
guess what they do
just take a hint runs in the family
movie reviews now it's definitely
different than the kind that I do
there's our more age appropriate wine uh
you know a certain audience which OSes
impose yeah buts bleeped a lot of the
time check it out there's a link in the
description box and all show a link
annotation in a bit for it to hear this
is so weird for me because this is just
so weird I'm so used to just having my
friends on or like when like a mom and
Meagan yeah it's just her yeah my sister
came on it was like so weird and
uncomfortable because we've never done
anything in front of the camera together
now we're doing something you and I have
we did stuff with AdvoCare whenever kids
yeah we were kids though we were just
tiny little munchkins
you were scary back then cuz you were
older you gonna do some serious martial
arts to keep a lookout for that this one
she's uh longer woman she's on her way
to just really adorable that's that's
about it that's her most natural talent
right now we're gonna watch some movie
clips today for dawn of the Planet of
the Apes did you see the first one cook
in kalui well I bought it actually
bought it for a recently she forced me
to she twisted my arm
to get it for her target this deals a
steel case one you see it I a sonnet I
like I liked it a lot I just wasn't the
biggest fan of um what's his name James
Frank James Franco I'm not a huge James
Franco fan
I liked him in spider-man too I think
and what else was he in oh I saw him in
128 127 hours mm-hmm that was good and
uh he was good in Spring Breakers
I did not see spring breakers Boise
looking spree looks good from the
trailer I was like wow that's that's
something that's so funny I'm smelling
me they smell funny
good rez my girls okay I like to go
places and pretend she's my kid it's way
easier to get girls that way they're
like he's a good single father really
working hard in life it's awesome I take
advantage of your daughter
not that I'm not gonna use that okay
first movie clip are gonna watch today
for Dawn
it's called koba's weapon hopefully I
said that right let's watch this
what do we do go swish ulam maybe I
think he likes oh you want a drink
oh [ __ ]
you didn't see that coming yeah I did
but it was still light that's not it
coming I was like this is not gonna be
good at all
feeling like a shocking manner there's a
way one town that was cool that was clip
I read I've been reading a lot of early
reviews of it and people are really
loving it like they're saying it's like
incredibly good I don't know if the
trust lately
I trust everything that is positive it's
that simple if I see movie has a 20
percent on Rotten Tomatoes you're like
oh who's that 20 all right this one's
called go take the wall screws it smells
like Jurassic Park yeah that's what it's
in the world
those are some good visual effects yeah
don't mean any harm
how's the guy from zero dark thirty
mm-hmm Jason Clark did they look like
just Apes
okay okay we're going damn it yeah the
visual effects got better because we
just watched the first one and there's a
clear delineation between the two in
terms of just equality yeah no I think
so too like it I mean sequels should
improve their visual effects so what do
you think so far Chloe alright so what
do you think the clips that you're
sitting do you want to see the movie now
she wanted to see it anyway
I like whether the tone that's means it
really does have like an apocalyptic
vibe about it
and I love Apocalypse movies like The
Book of Eli or something later than you
like people would be like hey that was
funny I really like it so ma'am I saw
that I think I got so upset I didn't
expect much from it you know that they
can remind the Bible can't the the
Braille Bible can't fit in a book like
that no is 27 volumes you wouldn't be
able to carry all that anyway whatever
yeah I think this much when I watch
sci-fi action films too but ya know with
this one I really do like everything
that's going on with it it's I love how
it doesn't feel like rise at all it
feels like a completely separate film I
remember the planet Eve sequels just
most of them like more not that great
this one I feel like they know what
they're doing we just bought the planet
of apes the Charlton Heston one it's a
good one at Costco and they made beneath
the Planet of the Apes which I heard was
really bad I never finished it so I
can't really say that but I love this
came from Planet which one is beneath
the that's the second one that's where
those like mine readers or some weird up
Cohen ogner has forgot I saw the one
that was based in like Washington DC
when they had like the baby yeah the
baby monkey was that beneath no that's
escaped okay that was scape is great
always a deuce I love escape but the
best ones of Tim Burton immersion never
forget that quote me that they have that
a Costco for nine bucks it's worth every
dollar it should if they raise the price
I would buy it that's one that's one
take me seriously on that okay so this
one is called hanging out the first clip
was like looking at the ape and seeing
like what they're capable of doing in
terms of manipulation this one's showing
that they're like really taking over now
we're gonna see a part of them where
they're just having fun Chloe you're
said yeah good feedback what smells like
you met having a face like that
like a real thing
gosh
Friday real nice afternoon
hanging out all this kegger down at this
women hanging out you can read
all right now you see that the film
still has a heart about it Chloe
you're talking really loud of her face
it I'm just trying to make sure she
understands thank you I do you like the
movie Chloe I am looking forward to
buying my ticket for this movie it's not
an IMAX as it's on Mad Max damn it's not
my thing if it's an IMAX I'm going on
max for that one if you ever see
anything in AMC IMAX don't sit in wrote
E it's a bad road so no universals m17
don't listen to me
keeps you live in California well thank
you guys for letting us know that these
movie clips are out because I'd ever
bother to check the internet myself for
these things so thank you if you're new
to the channel what you can do is be
awesome like the awesome person or you
could check out their channel called
Jeff and the worst brother ah Jabby koi
Jabba koi Shevek away
what does Jabby Kois now for not I'm not
I'm not let's not go Jackie Chan shut up
youtube.com/ stash J APO a1 whoa J a BYU
koat 1 very good there you go
yep yeah it's spelled for them at the
bottom already but yeah thanks thank you
for doing that bro um okay well guys I'm
gonna need your help brother of mine I
had so normally I give shoutouts at the
end of these videos Internet currently
down got a calling T and T see what's up
there so um I have to kind of go off the
top of my head right now and just thank
a few people and you guys can give a
shout-out to some person either one
person as well do one shout out each
person how about that I want to give a
shout out to someone who I haven't
mentioned awhile hot subscriber Michelle
Fernandes you are gorgeous
and you stay that way and if you ever
come to California find me I'll be Ryan
right around the corner from shout out
to Molly mm-hmm
mmm-hmm no they she understands the
concept of a shadow you're just just
she's gonna watch this and then she's
gonna hear you say hi to her and it's
awesome
because this is going to be viewed by a
lot of people know you don't want to
hide your mouth I'm gonna give a shout
out some I'm gonna give a shout-out to
my mom I love you mom
you're awesome you're the best mom in
the world now is your shoutout
that's the full extent are you oh it's
still going okay next